Lake George stretches for 32 miles in
New York State they call it the queen of
American leagues but even so it faces
many threads they include pollution from
stormwater runoff and excess nutrients
to better understand the league and
these threats researchers and I p.m.
have started a project it's called the
Jefferson project last week more than 60
scientists from many different fields
began to collect data they have spent 18
months testing advanced sensors while
some of these are in the water others
are on land in total there are 40
platforms these sensors will monitor 25
different variables including weather
and water chemistry the communicate with
one another they report data wirelessly
in real time researchers will use
computers to analyze the data they will
be able to create better
three-dimensional models these models
work together to visualize things like
whether water currents food webs why is
all of this important the data and the
models could help people manage and
protect Lake George and lakes all over
the world
you